I'm about.
To answer the internet. I had bronchitis.
Would you rather know when you're going to die or how you're going to die?
Dang, these are good questions.
I would rather know how I'm going to die because I'd rather know like what to
know indoors or outdoors, probably.
So I can kind of be prepared on how to not dress, but how to, like,
I don't want to die in the wrong shoes, you know,
would you rather have a dog's personality and a cat body or a cat's personality
and adult body? I'm not sure exactly, but I don't want to be a cat at all.
So whatever one of these is not being a cat, you know, um.
See that's the thing you would have the dog body, but the brain of a cat.
So you kind of are a cat, but then the other way you'd have the body of a cat.
Everyone would think you're a cat.
So would you rather know you're a cat or have other people think you're a cat?
I'd rather probably do euthanasia, you know? Yeah.
No offense to cats or anything, but also cats.
So basically there's pieces of loneliness that are in your apartment.
If you had to pick one person to be the ambassador for the human race to meet
aliens, who would it be? Ooh, this is good. I probably pay,
um, I'll be a Filipino dude. I'm really infatuated about Filipinos.
They're happy. They're joyous. You know,
they call them the smiling people somewhere on the internet. And um,
and every Filipino I meet, they're real gracious.
They do a lot of senior care centers, hospice. So you don't,
who else are you going to send out there, dude? You know what I'm saying?
A drunk, you know, uh,
somebody from Scotland know somebody on Coke and can't do any of that.
You got to send somebody who is caring, I think.
Can you just say like the RA? Oh, you mean like a specific person? You know,
who's good on Filipino. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Maybe Manny Pacquiao there.
Would you rather be blind or dickless dude these days? Probably dickless.
I think I had a blind kid in my neighborhood when I was growing up. And uh,
actually, you know, this dude was deaf actually. And,
and they beat him up for doing bad magic because he was always doing all of this
and and people thought he was doing magic with no tricks and they beat him.
So would you rather go to jail for one year or go to jail with a Rubik's
cube and you can leave what it's done?
Yeah.
Science one. Huh? I would rather, I go to jail for a year.
I think it'd be great. These days, relaxing, get some reading done,
you know, get in shape, you know, get beat up and rape them.
Get some diverse friends.
Okay. How long is it? You do receive a Rubik's cube.
I bet I could probably do it in a week,
so, but you'll take the year.
Oh dude. I'd love to have some time to just relax, honestly.
And I'm a pretty simple man, as long as yeah.
If I'm in there are the lights on at night though.
That would be the part that would exist.
Would you rather have everyone naked all the time or everyone closed all the
time? I'm okay. Pretty much with how things are.
I think so I would say clothes.
It's a big question to ask and just assume somebody is going to change it.
Based on that question,
would you rather sit down with your parents and watch every sexual encounter
you've had or watch your parents' sex tape when they conceived you?
I don't know, man. My dad was 70 when I was born, so, Oh.
I probably watched a tape, honestly, man, I think it would be cool.
Would almost be artistic these days.
I'd be looked at it more as art than it would be as something to deviant.
Do you think there was more porn stars or murders in the world?
I think murderers, you know,
I actually know a guy probably shouldn't say this on here,
but I'm not gonna say names, but I know a guy who killed someone and he said,
and this isn't me saying this dude, I wouldn't do something like this.
But he said that it feels good.
And he did say that.
Do you know how he murdered them? Do you know how he murdered him?
I don't know anything else, man. Let me see that.
Would you take $4 million to be able to catch a predator? Um, I would take it,
uh, I would take about $700 back.
Cause Chris Hanson was on my podcast and he tried to run up a bunch of hotel
bills with spa stuff, extra spot treatments and stuff like that.
So Chris Hanson tried to me on about $730. You know, getting Rose pedals and.
Well, Adam, as soon as he called you names, but I wouldn't do that to you.
And I would appreciate that. You know, you shouldn't try to do that to us.
Cause we were trying to be, you know, some Patty co what STD,
how many of these do you have do this.
But I'll stop eventually. Don't worry.
Uh, what STD would you be willing to have if you were able to pass it onto your
biggest enemy? I'd probably say something new,
something they wouldn't see coming, you know? Uh,
some of that seems fun and then it's, and then it's not, and then you, you know,
it's not fun and you die. So.
STD seems like it's fun.
Something's fun out of the gate. Some of that sounds good. You know, like, uh,
I don't know. There's some foods that also sound like STDs or Def Leppard.
That sounds like an STD. Which fictional character would you love to be
beat the out of dude? I don't know if I can meet a lot of people.
I think I could beat that dude from the mask. You ever seen that movie mask,
but Rocky Dennis, I could fight that dude. I bet who else? Probably Rosie.
O'Donnell that's not a fictional character. That's a real person. Depends on me.
Yeah,
But I'll shut that thick fella down.
You know that if you were sent back to the Roman empire with a fully shards,
iPhone, do you think you could take over the world?
no, dude. I think he would probably beat you up.
They would say you're gay and they would beat you
To be honest and no offense. If anybody's down, I might be gay. So this is it.
Yeah. And no offense to you. I just don't have anything else to say.
And I feel bad talking this much.
How long would it take for you to drink all the water and above ground pool?
Oh man, this is.
Good, dude. I.
Don't know, man, probably.
I bet a year and a half. It's a very solid answer.
You'd be surprised how many people are like.
Oh, no way, dude, bro. And also you can't drink consecutive.
You can only drink about a gallon straight before like the electrolytes in your
body switch up and you can die. So dude,
I drank a gallon in my buddy Tim's house. One time went to take a nap, bro.
on his floor, 12 by 12 square foot room dude.
And the pool touched all four walls, bro.
But thank you guys so much for having me, man. I appreciate it. Yeah.
Thanks a lot. Yeah, you bet, man. That was so much fun, dude.